just been finished for a while
so hot
Thursday Thursday hey really sweet night
alright so we put in a big day of
training today down at Donner Lake we
swam we ran we did it like 10 times I'm
exhausted
we got a little grub that we got a
little rest and now we're going to do a
podcast another coaches corner of
podcast with Chris he really did start
cracking up I know I don't know I don't
know if I could trust you to just zip it
I'm gonna pull you on the mic don't
worry dude I'm exhausted
yeah it was a fun day or the learning
experience but the good thing is is that
you went through the same struggles that
I did the first time I came up here by
myself that's comforting emotions I was
alarmed about all the things that you
experienced I experienced experience the
first time and I was worried too yeah
well let's uh provide a little context
we're up in Lake Tahoe Donner Lake to be
specific for a 48 hour training camp and
today so we're at 6,000 feet of altitude
I can't tell you the last time I been up
and altitude let alone train to Delta 2
and today we put in an epic day of
training of swimrun it was the first
time that we've we trained together
except that one other time but but the
first time that we trained together in
the wet suits with the running shoes on
with the paddles with the whole shebang
in what was supposed to be cold water
yeah a little cold acclamation and we
trained from like I don't know 6:30 to
1:30 or something like that
ten different swim run segments all over
Donner Lake mm-hmm yeah and so break it
down what do we do you remember started
off with a three-mile swim close to
three mile swim across the lake from one
end to the other basically almost the
full length and then we ran back to
where we started then really miles yeah
we did a shorter swim which was supposed
to be a little shorter but I got lost on
time and next thing you know was
actually a 35 minute swim versus uh just
a one-mile swim and then we ran once
around the lake which is approximately
seven miles and then it started getting
hot yeah that was the first time and
then
we threw in another few short swims with
a few short runs and then we finished it
up with another long run around the lake
right it's about that was about was that
five four I can't remember how long that
final run was always six mile oh is it
six because we swam for art of
everything yeah right we swam part of it
because we jumped in on that one and
swam to the beat and then jumped out and
started running right and we're both
wearing these prototype Roca wetsuits
that are cut off just above the knee and
have full length on the sleeves zip down
the front which is unusual for a weapon
for what to have pockets on both both
quads where you can put a little
nutrition or whatever you want and we
both had pull buoy strapped to our
thighs with surgical tubing and so this
is how we swam with the paddles with the
pull buoys with the shoes on the whole
time getting out of the water and then
running with all this gear in what
quickly turned into 80 degree weather
running in wetsuits at altitude Donner
Lake and it was it started out comical
then it became excruciating ly painful
at least it was for me I know you felt
good but I was chasing your ankles all
day long flat I was black wetsuit
I'm still in that Sun and then you had a
swim cap on the whole time yeah so that
made it extra hot I finally had to tell
you so he develop some cap off while
you're running yeah it was rough man I
you know I've been doing plenty of swim
runs in the pool and you know and and
doing it in in hot weather you know in
Los Angeles upwards of 100 105 this was
a totally different deal like at home I
actually feel good running out of the
pool
I can easily throw down you know 7:15
7:30 pace with a you know with a
rational heart rate anywhere between 132
to 140 but today I was struggling to run
830 miles with a heart rate that was
just skyrocketed you know like in the
160 like I never get my heart rate up
that high it was crazy so I presume that
that is a factor of the thirty four mile
run that I did like two days ago the
altitude the heat and running in a
wetsuit with all this gear
I'm hoping but it was it was tossed man
it was definitely eye-opening for me and
a little bit of an awakening and a
little scared yeah I mean well we also
shock the system pretty hard you just
got back from an international trip time
change sleep and all that and then we
right away through you into a five-hour
one run which turned out to be 34 miles
for you and then 48 hours later we're
here at out here dude so we've never
settled you in giving you a time to
absorb the load that we've been giving
you so yeah I mean a lot happen today
but I think was a really good experience
for you to also to see those numbers
know you can continue suffer a little
bit which is what we will be dealing
there and it's good for the headspace
too yeah normally I would not have taken
a two-week adventure literally a month
out from a huge race like this but
that's just life and I went to Ireland
and I was in Portland and I did my best
to try to maintain some semblance of
training when I was traveling but it's
not like it is at home of course so I
came back you know lacking some fitness
I mean maybe absorbing the fitness the
training that I had put in prior to that
but really kind of taking a break in the
middle of you know what should have been
a really intense period of ramping up so
my longest run prior to those trips was
about two hours and 40 minutes and
normally I would have stepped it up you
always have me step it up like three
hours three and a half four four and a
half up to five but I went from that two
and a half hour came back from my trip
and threw down a five hour run you know
without that kind of buildup I mean I
can do it but it's going to rattle me
you know much more than it would have
had I more responsibly acclimated to
that kind of load yeah and in comparison
for the last few weeks I have been great
you have been doing that right and I've
also had some recovery in between but I
did be three and a half then the four
and a half and so then the five two days
ago because we synched up our training
plan for a week so that we come in
exactly with the same loads and training
and so on so that we could mimic
everything here just right and yeah you
know it's a different process for me
right and you know also out of fairness
I've been
for years now long runs and you're sort
of building into this realm I mean
when's the last time you did it thirty
four mile round man I mean I don't even
know I was having some like nickels and
stuff ramping up to Ultraman 2011 and
running was challenging for me so I
don't even know if I put in like a 40
mile run prior to that race so I think
it's been 2009 was the last time I put
in like big time runs sorry week next
week yeah yeah I know what were this
shock to the system that we just did
were three weeks out a couple
observations on today the first thing is
I thought the whole pool pulley strapped
to the quad thing was going to be a pain
in the butt and get in the way and just
be annoying but actually it was no big
deal
totally comfortable with that and the
idea of swimming with shoes and then
running in wet shoes with socks I was
concerned about that but we both found
shoes that seemed to work well with our
feet and if that didn't bother me at all
I was surprised about that the thing I
think I was most surprised beyond what I
already said just you know being it
being as difficult as it was today was
how hot I was getting like the the
rubber on this wetsuit especially around
the quads is super thick and it was a
hot day out and it's unbelievable how
overheated you get running he's like who
runs in a wetsuit nobody does that so I
am that's what wrestlers do to lose
weight to make awake you know it means I
think they had a few times yeah they as
you're running around the lake some of
those people must have been looking at
us just going to trying to lose weight
writing yeah it's funny there's a loop
around Donner Lake and this is high
season and there's a lot of people here
on vacation etc people are out palpable
you know on their paddle boards and
boating and running and biking and all
that kind of stuff and there's two guys
running down the street in wet suits
holding holding bright orange hand
paddles in their hands while they're
running with a pole wearing it today
yeah when we start and I'm wearing a
swim cap you know brightly it's like I
thought we'd get a lot more like strange
looks than we did and people are like
whatever I guess you know maybe OSA
spent five out here in Truckee but yeah
not only seen a lot of triathletes up
here from the years of the Ironman up
and so a lot of people asked me today
probably about six are you guys training
for a triathlon I'm going said no
actually we're doing something a little
different right so what do we have left
like what do you what's your takeaway
from today what do we have to work on
still I thought we had like pretty good
communication I I was disappointed that
I wasn't able to hold pace with you at
least I'm going swimming and you know
maybe that's just you know for the
reasons we've already stated but overall
I feel like our communication is good
like we're in sync I just have to bridge
that gap a little bit more I think over
the next three weeks yeah and I'm not
really too worried about your fitness
come the day because we just needed that
day we didn't need it today the good
communication yeah and I think we also
have a good unspoken language of knowing
that when you need something or when you
don't and now that worked well today I
would say the thing that we both noticed
with the hand paddles to how much harder
they really are a kin yeah and then
using those muscles after just having
swum a lot of course we stacked our day
a little bit differently
nobody's going to be doing a three mile
swim to start Oh till oh right right
that we basically did half the distance
right to start off of the full Atilla
distance so but still it is eye-opening
how you have to be aware of that and
then I think the other thing we'll want
to pay more attention to is our
transition they were somewhat slow yeah
and they also took my cap off and how
much was to put my cap on and I'm
holding these hand paddles and like
trying to get my goggles on you know I
was like that's a mess well we have to
just bigger I've been with that many
transitions a minute here and there will
quickly turn into an hour right
look at that time just adds up so often
so much and then other than that though
it went pretty smoothly I mean I know
we're both praying for that cold water
although I know come race day we're not
going to be praying yeah not that cold
yeah exactly and yeah but that's just
the learning of today and then applying
it specifically to these next three
weeks to really incorporate those last
details that we'll need
one of the questions that always comes
up that people are asking me is like how
are you feeling these workouts like what
are you eating
and I don't often respond to those
because it's kind of a boring answer
like I don't overthink it too much I
mean we woke up at 5:30 I had a bowl of
cereal and what you know what did you
you I think you have the same yeah I ate
a banana I had a cup of coffee and then
we went and then we had some little bars
that we chewed on at a couple of the
transitions and we made sure that we
were drinking water we used your pickup
truck as kind of a home base where we
had some nutrition products there but it
wasn't like we were caring like I wasn't
carrying nutrition with me or anything
like that like it we kept it pretty
minimal I don't think we yeah we kept it
pretty well and I think we also gapped
it well enough in comparison to the race
because there it's going to be 45 to 60
minutes between those energy stations
and so I want us to be ready to just go
that long and feel a little bit of
hunger and know what to grab and be
prepared as we're going into that I mean
that's the things that those are the
little details will we as a team working
together it's going to be real effective
because we'll be able to communicate say
what we want know what we're kind of
calories we were looking for going into
each aid station energy station and then
come out of it pretty efficiently the
minutes were spending putting on caps at
transitions we might make up in those
aid stations yeah yeah I think Hunter
McIntyre was the person who told me he's
like you just got to keep moving yeah
like just keep moving because I think
the Trent you're right the transitions I
think are where people are stopping or
you're looking for your partner you get
spaced out from that person and there's
a lot of pausing and looking around and
fiddling around with your gear and like
you said that stuff adds up so
minimizing that I think is going to be
key I'm a little worried about that yeah
I mean I really line will be fine and
that's the fun - anything - as a team I
can help you through that logistic time
right like rich are we thinking of this
are we doing this we're just constantly
communicating and that'll be important
with those shorter distances 300 metres
swim 500 meter run like that we're
talking you know and that we know what's
coming up ahead not that we know the
distances or what island it is right but
that we know what we're getting
ourselves alright we got a short swim
here let's really try to stretch it out
push a little bit and then recover on
that next longer island well we're in
our three right now we still want to
hold back here a little bit nutrition
fueling is going well well well hydrated
our strategy is X and therefore this is
what we're going to do for the next 45
minutes no matter what the terrain or
the water brings because we just want to
manage our energy levels pretty
efficiently through the day so that we
can do things faster when we're able to
when the road open it up when the
terrain
allows it for us like you and I
bushwhacking like it will be that's not
our strength that's where we need to get
to it efficiently and not using a lot of
energy but then when the road opens up
and we have some pavement or flatter
trails or steady effort then we can
start pushing a little bit right right
right so we've been breaking open like
the looking at the website and all the
requirements and all the stuff we got to
get like we got to get we have to do we
each have to carry a first aid pack I
think as a team appears and I'd want but
we each have a whistle yeah we have to
carry a whistle so we put that around
our neck right yeah and that I mean what
if you get into trouble I about yeah oh
yeah safety of the this the best when
vessels that will come and help you
right and it's nothing guaranteed but it
just helps them day I mean remember the
history of this race you used to have to
carry so much safety equipment keep in
mind when they started this race you had
to swim with the life vest like the full
$1 to have on a boat right and then you
had to you could barely swim because
your arms are just sticking out the side
and it would take the swimmers part of
the race out of it because nobody can
swim fast right Matt and so they reduced
the safety gear over the years to that
whistle that first aid kit and then a
compass mm-hmm you have a compass but
that's the best thing we were joking the
other day at dinner like I don't know
what like what would I even do with this
like how is this going to help me like I
hear you're ordering because there's
always doors like I don't know what
direction I'm going
yeah you know if I have to break out the
compass I got bigger problems yes well I
will just stay in one place everybody
helps blow a whistle really loud until
somebody comes that's my plan yeah so
all right so we got three weeks left
what is it what's this window going to
look like we will start pulling back
here pretty quickly I mean we definitely
need to recover from this week this is a
big week and it's good to just have felt
that fatigue and working our way through
it the way we did I mean going through
the difficulties of a steady five-hour
day five and a half hour day like today
is important I'm going to just put you
back into that mindset of just keep
trucking right let just keep moving
forward
don't overanalyze the pace don't
overanalyze the heart rate just keep
moving forward right yeah start doing a
little bit of self-talk and there's
times today we're on top for a reason I
ran ahead of you because I wanted you to
reacquaint yourself with that and that's
what we'll need where you just sort of
have that silent communication of saying
you know what we'll just give him his
phase in this you're running ahead and
then all that means is I start looking
at my watch and I start looking at my
heart rate on my pace and stuff like
vlogging myself yeah but no that's good
I mean yeah obviously we've got to
absorb this training and then you know
then we're coming weeks out and then we
got to do a little refining on the speed
stuff I would imagine and maybe work on
some of the logistics around transitions
and some of the technique stuff well
there will be doing some transition
stuff some trail stuff - I'd like to get
us a little bit more familiar with the
bushwhacking aspect which I've done some
research but I just wanted to get even
more unfamiliar with it and I say
unfamiliar because it's something that
you can't really prepare for that
terrain over ice weeding but at least
that we've done some running through
that and see what that's going to be
like I mean that's just going off trail
basically right so today we weren't
wearing compression socks and like I
said earlier our wetsuits just were
captive of the knee but with all that
you know brambles and all the kind of
stuff that we're going to encounter it's
been advised that we wear
form of compression stock just so you're
not getting yourself all scratched up
and I think they even have products that
are like buoyant shin guard or whatever
for extra point like there's all kinds
of crazy you can go down the rabbit hole
on all this kind of thing and that's I
mean that's overall the big picture
strategy and it's been affirmed the very
beginning that our fitness allows us to
overcome things that we really aren't
familiar with with this race right of
course we could do it this year and then
try to go back next year well we have
some familiarity and then you get more
specific with it but because we don't
know the race the best way to compensate
for that so I ask friends and get more
input is to be extra sick for it my and
extra prepared and and for us also
rested like we don't want to waste your
fitness leave Fitness up on a Malibu
Canyon run instead of in Sweden right
yeah I think if we have a strength it is
that endurance base you know putting in
those huge days and the weakness is you
know unfamiliarity with the terrain and
what this race is all about and just in
experience with this kind of event
overall yeah yeah but I mean that's part
of the fun right we're doing it as its
yeah and and like we said from the
beginning we're doing this for fun you
guys like we're not winning this I mean
like we're competitive people we're
going to try to you know do the best
that we can and like and be in the hunt
and all that kind of good stuff but you
know we're not delusional and you know
had had this performance got like had
that been my you know on my radar like I
wouldn't have gone to Ireland I wouldn't
have done these I would have I would
have had a different kind of focus going
into this but that's not my life right
now and you know it's cool like I said
on Instagram and then you chastise me
because obviously because it's like this
is a team thing you know so my primary
motivator is yeah I want to do well but
I don't want to let you down you know
our our destinies are inextricably
tethered to each other well and that
brings up a good point it's the
motivation that you've had over the last
six months has been helped knowing that
you're working with a teammate right and
it's a lot of cases with a lot of people
listening or just in general with health
and fitness is it's hard by yourself but
if you have somebody that you're not
necessarily accountable to but that
you're looking forward to
doing this with it might be a really
good thing for everybody just to
consider what do I need to get myself
motivated to train more consistently
maybe a event with a partner or a
challenge with a partner because it does
help and as you've probably seen the
last few months where there in Ireland
or as you've been traveling or just
getting up on some of those hard
mornings or it's like I got to do this I
love to do it for myself but there's a
little extra you know with that hey I'm
racing with somebody right and I want to
do well with them for them as a team
yeah for sure I'm excited I'm sorry I'm
a little bit scared after today as we've
I think it's just it's ramping up my my
attention like my sort of focus on what
needs to be done between now and that
yeah and and back to what you said with
regards to us not winning I think in a
lot of sports it's somewhat the lack of
a better term disrespectful for us to
think that we can just train for nine
months and come in there and something
we've never done and these people have
been training for years and there's a
whole circuit there's a circuit these
guys are doing these races all the time
they know exactly what how this stuff
works and for us maybe for us oh we want
to get top three or top five or whatever
the number is I think is not fair to the
sport either we want to make a good
showing we want to represent ourselves
we want to have fun that's the key thing
too and you know just have a great day
in a great location at a great adventure
I mean that's the product ideal yeah
that's a very good point and it has been
fun I mean I think it's been a
refreshing you know reprieve from the
grind of triathlon or just ultra running
because it is so adventure based like
we're cracking up on the eye we have
burkle over here Carolyn Burke I'm going
to bring you on in the mic in a second
but we were laughing so hard this
morning on the dock like you put your
wet suit on backwards of course and I'm
like how do I put this pull the we thing
is like a comedy of errors like we're
just trying to figure out like how do we
do this you know it's like and we're
three weeks out it's like you know we
should have probably done this several
months ago or done one of these camps
like every month leading up to this to
be respond are late for the
I know yeah it is and there's a third it
there is a there's something cool about
just kind of letting all that go and
just being like it is for fun and but
keep in mind all this we've gotten
through it healthy we're not injured
right I mean that's the hardest part if
you get too tense with this and too
focused on a lot of this stuff
especially ultra-endurance stuff this is
an 8 to 9 hour 10 hour 11 hour event you
can quickly push yourselves to something
that you're not familiar with that
you're getting injured yeah
and that's our goal we want to come into
this fit somewhat ready alright have fun
and be ready to give it our best run on
a challenging hard course I mean this
place is notorious for being really hard
yeah even the locals say I mean that
whole archipelago out there supposedly
is just bizarre I mean there's it's just
really tough exposed different men we're
just going to slip and run across it
right so it's cut it's called Utah I
think it's the town and when we arrive
the day is a day before the race we take
a ferry to this island is an island yeah
for this one what we're learning you and
then all the all the competitors and
everybody associated with the race camps
out there and we're in like tents or
something like that like I still don't
even well in it yeah right certain feed
for dinner right and then it's a 4 a.m.
wake-up call and then we do it but we're
we're sequestered it's not like we're
starting in Stockholm or something like
that like we're just we're out there in
the middle of nowhere for this thing you
know we're going to meet a bunch of
great competitors and people and and I
mean that's just all so unique and it's
a different adventure every piece of it
like no imagine at an Ironman or and
also taken every competitor and
sequestering them for even a 9 24 hours
prior to the race people be freaking out
yeah yeah yeah speaking of injuries
berkel you don't get on the mic here for
a second here slide that over her for a
minute so we have Caroline Buerkle here
who is a
former Olympian in swimming swam for the
University of Florida and she had the
best intentions of competing at belleau
with Hillary with Alou with the huh I'm
going to get created for not saying it
right I need to try very hard you guys I
really am
caroline was going to be competing with
hillary Biscay former podcast guest
ultraman world champion but due to well
Caroline got an injury you got you have
a serious bone fracture in your heel
yeah
so that counted you out first time I
heard the word calcaneus in my life and
I'm jokes but yet calcaneal stress
factor you show me the the x-ray again
it's for real yeah it's pretty gnarly
and I didn't know about it until about
six weeks after I did it apparently
mm-hmm so I kept pushing it running on
it were you just touched on you know not
being injured and being healthy and
going through something this has been
the biggest learning lesson for me just
going through something and knowing now
how to train versus not logging stuff
not paying attention just running miles
in the mountains will help you didn't
yeah yeah yeah I mean one of the things
that that Chris is really good about is
tempering that desire to ramp up too
quickly and being very diligent and
erring on the side of less is more in
terms of ramping up the running in
particular to avoid just these very
scenarios when it's important to I mean
obviously none of us have done a race
like this but it's important when you're
in a position of endurance training that
you're keeping your strength in these
little places of your body that you
don't even realize that you need
strength in so I've learned the
importance of your feet there's this
process I like doing towel grabs in like
golf ball grabs of my toes and things
like that before I would laughed and
scoffed at that and now it's it's so
important so never underestimate the
yeah yeah well it was it was a bummer
because we had this whole plan we were
going to be all these crazy Americans
going over to you know meet this race
head-on it was going to be you and
Hillary and then Hunter McIntyre was
partnering up with your friend
Rory right and then that's not happening
either so now it's just something like
I'm here so now she's just Chris and I
then Erica Mara condemnatory
is been you know well I'm in all
seriousness like you guys you said it so
many times inside guys and I'm so far
and I've wanted to say something I was
really trying to be quiet over here in
the corner however you guys you know you
nailed it with just not knowing
sometimes as best you may not know the
Train you may not know the race and
sometimes I feel like going into
something with a little bit more of a
naive attitude like think like a child
child like mine like when you go into it
with an idea and you have a plan you
know you're fit and like you said you
have your fitness it's fun sometimes you
can overthink when you have so much that
you're supposed to be knowing and
memorizing and all this I think the
whole part of it will be like where are
we going let's go ahead yeah let's talk
during this five hundred meter dash
across puces know there's something
beautiful about that you know it
provides that space for just like fun
and joy like I remember the first time I
did altra man like my crew is my dad you
know I'm like this other buddy of mine
who had no like you I it was like it's
over Thanksgiving weekend so it's really
hard to find people to help you out
because everybody has plans and I got
this ragtag crew of buddies and my dad
to come out and they like we didn't know
anything you know but that made it super
fun you know it's like sort of look at
this and you know through a similar life
and yeah and you remember that's most
I'm sure other races are awesome and
you've got it all going on but you
remember the ones the most are just like
well here we go and it's cool that even
though you have this injury I mean
you've been walking around in a boot
you're not in the food anymore but that
you were just game to come up to Tahoe
for the week and even though you can't
run to like do the swim and just kind of
hang out yeah you know I took swimming
for granted forever when I retired some
pool swimming and professional something
I hated it for so long and now I
absolutely will never again take it for
granted just because it is something
that no impact for the rest of your
lives you can do it it's incredible and
there's nothing like a swimming high
when you just are done flowing even
today that's three miles across I mean
that transition was pretty quick
afterwards guys
but you know we're all talking and
having fun that was sarcasm by the way
we're all talking about and fun and I
was just like you know you all went off
on your run and I'm standing at my car
and I was like that was unbelievable we
just were cool fresh you know three
miles at 6:00 7:00 a.m. and it felt like
20 seconds of times it just all those
looking over it oh my gosh so who's not
fun yeah I know but be clear Carolyn was
way out front yeah like just for the
record she's way ahead of us and then
she'd roll onto her back and picture
goggles and I'm like back there going oh
my god yeah actually at one point I see
you pop your head up and just like start
shaking your head at me like how about
you all have shoes on and Bowie and I
did not I was totally shoeless so thank
you you had an advantage you're
ridiculously fit are you one of those
people that just never retired and you
just stayed fit out there we Connor
do we start Pilates don't know it but
yeah yeah after that I was like I I
signed up for like three ragnar realize
in a span of six months and I was like
let's do this
that's so slipping every single day
still well every other day but I mean
that but then again you know we can go
on a whole nother topic with that but
maybe a little time off was needed in
this been injury of six to eight weeks
no it's I mean six to eight weeks in the
boot but it's been about 12 since I have
run at all steps foot even in that
direction but um I think my adrenals are
finally repaired times that you've got
to listen to your body yeah I want mine
I want to do like a whole podcast with
you because I want to get like your
whole story because it's super
interesting
that's not today but I do want you to
tell that story that you told the other
last night about the adrenal fatigue
yeah yeah it's so there's a lot to it so
with what with the waking up in the
middle of the night with my trans dad
like your whole swimming career waking
up in the night with I mean I saw toes
of my bed sheets just drenched and I
would send them to we'd send them in to
the doctors and I mean I'm not sitting
here no I want anybody kidding me or
anything it was just one of those things
that's alarming and you don't know but
you got to keep going you don't have a
choice mm-hmm you know a choice you got
to keep going I mean I guess I didn't
you probably don't know
but I hope that Greg joy would have been
super stuff yet me clearly a
communication of adrenal fatigue
um but you may not even feel tired like
if that's happening even in your tit you
feel good like I'm not over trained you
know but it's so deep because in the
years and years and years without you
know taking the requisite you know rest
weeks or those down periods that allow
your like your your base to like reset
so that you can you know have longevity
in your career and so I go to how to
feel yourself properly to repair those
it's huge and so having that stress
fracture you said correct me if I'm
wrong but you said the other night like
just the other day was like the first
night that you didn't wake up with with
that sweats and like as long as you can
remember
yeah about two weeks ago I called my
doctor and said oh my gosh
you know and he's an herbal you know
he's even unbelievable naturopath and
that was just like I can't believe it I
just woke up without sweating for like
three four nights in a row and it was
weird like I I noticed that I woke up
without it and it it was exciting but
then of course you know you have that
athlete's mind where you're like well
that means I'm not dreaming right but
then I had to call it you have to calm
yourself back down and say this is in
two months this is going to be this is
going to pay off like I think might be
the best thing that ever happened to you
ever what does it design you would
you're the kind of person who would had
just dug your grave and just you know
grind it until like your body just caved
in completely I would have gone one more
week on my heal it would've broken all
the way through and I would have fit six
pins in it yeah I mean like the image
not happy it is like cracked in half
your hell like and that's just from run
that's insane yeah so and you know you I
thought I knew my body and I'm honored
that and I always have told myself oh
you are so in tune with your body and
now this is humbling for me to take a
step back and like maybe I'm not listen
maybe maybe I need to be real with
myself and I think we all have a
reminder in that and it your body
changes every year and you know I'm not
20 anymore yeah and if you take that
seriously then then you'll be able to go
to a whole different level I think
and you'll have much more longevity and
you'll be healthier and you'll just be
able to compete with you know joy and
without that kind of fatigue like you
know I mean we're from different eras
but you know Chris and I will both tell
you like I was
I slept walked through my you know teens
and 20s like I didn't even know what's
going on you know so exhausted all the
time yeah yeah and I mean I think I lost
15 pounds when I was done swimming I
know how to do anything for my body all
I was doing was cardio no strength
training wasn't eating properly wasn't
sleeping and I don't think even a year
though I could have made that three mile
swim without stopping ten times and
wanted to die and today it was just like
it felt incredible you know and I it was
it's just something that you know and of
course like three miles eight years ago
would be a laughingstock when Joey not
for warmup but now it's like yeah you
know when you're in open water and
you're just you just feel incredible so
and it's no easy feat so yeah I think
that and also it's taught me a lot when
we're working with our teen athletes and
working with them on injuries or
overcoming things like that like I have
a whole new respect and a whole new
understanding so it helps me do what I
do better and able to impact that
generation to slow down be patient
listen to your body and learn how to
listen your body cuz of this you know
there are your actions now your body I
mean because yeah here so give it back
back Mike whatta fukk here no no no
because I want to disinfect it's a
natural segue anyway because but it's
hard to learn signals like we learn the
signals in swimming over so many years
what to look for like for example with
your heel that's not really something
that you would have noticed because
that's not an injury you would never get
swimming so we also it takes a while to
learn the different aspects of lifts
listening to your body and it's it's
very complicated and it's not a perfect
science either many people will give you
different inputs of what different
things mean I mean night sweats
you can ask 10 doctors they'll give you
five different answers yeah so and from
anything from nutrition to overtraining
- you know chronic fatigue even going
far into the into the whole mm-hmm
so in the course of your coaching I mean
triathletes tend to be well-heeled
type-a highly driven personalities and
talking them down off that cliff has got
to be a challenge when they want to just
gun run a gun
yeah on the one hand I don't work with a
lot of athletes that aren't willing to
understand that and that means I turn
down or after sometimes some athletes
just aren't willing to do that and we
don't work together anymore but I always
quote to them that if you're thinking
about getting sick that'll be the easy
part like I can get you fit be patient
will get you really fit sitter than
you've ever been before but if we try to
jump the gun on this your fitness is
it's never going to materialize right
we're going to be in four weeks from now
you're either going to be off the
program
not logging your workouts because you
feel guilty that you're not logging your
workouts right and you're injured or
you're too tired or you can't make it
fit and we talked about this last right
it's like making it all balanced as a
masters athlete with work and family and
life you just have to be patient because
the sickness is building and again the
what Carolyn just said is that so many
years of swimming and so on deck that
won't go away like you think four or
five months right oh my god like go on
forever right two weeks when we took off
two weeks once a year swimming and
Germany it was like over oh my god like
I'm gonna need a six-month rebuild like
you're like what no but you it's so deep
in your system and sort of what I was
alluding to before you took five years
of lighter training I mean it took you
only six months to get back to pretty
good fitness that you can walk in or
walk out the door and run 34 miles with
no real proper build-up now we do have
to be careful now the next few days that
we don't this is where the Nagle show up
in ten days you know you did on Tuesday
if we're not smart if something will
creep up and then you'll be really
pumped right ten day five so we
really got to be careful with this
window yeah yeah yeah I mean because
this is not the normal protocol we would
have built up much more responsibly so
they say you can't cram for an event so
there's a little bit of a cram here that
that ordinarily would not be the program
but in my experience of working with you
one thing that you always do is you just
you wait wait longer than even I knowing
you and knowing how you work like okay
I'm ready
you know like I'm ready to come on when
is the hard work it like I'm ready for
the harder workouts oh no no no not yet
you know you got it you got it you got a
you got a train to Train and then you
got a train to Train and then you got a
train and then you train you know but if
you jump that gun like you see it all
the time people are getting injured
injured because the lungs and the cardia
like that comes along quick and then
you're like I'm I'm good I'm ready - I'm
ready to go yeah but your whole body is
a fine-tuned machine that everything has
to work in sync to do the volume that
we're talking about we're not talking
about a two hour workout here we're
talking about six seven eight hours you
know at a time as some pretty high
intensities if we're getting ready for a
triathlon or you know this type of stuff
I mean it's a lot on the body and people
underestimate just because they feel
good today and tomorrow that they're
ready month during the weekend or
whenever and three four days to do it
again and know it takes longer you know
and former patients you know most most I
mean patients in the context of years
right while it's endurance sports it's a
natural filter if you don't have the
patients the best athletes will not be
able to materialize if you're patient
and you will get fit and it will blossom
more than you ever thought it would be I
mean some of the signs that I always
talk about with regards to fitness is
when you finish a Half Ironman or an
Ironman and you recover in 10 to 12 days
and you're excited to train again and
you're ready to go that's a sign of
fitness right not that I'm going to let
them try and right away but there's that
quickly recovered their knots or four
weeks or they're not um low-energy four
weeks they're not walking around and
meeting sweet and so on for weeks
they're just popping right back and
that's real deep Fitness be awareness
yeah the awareness that's right so right
before this little jaunt up here you
were in Boulder and you were the
endurance coach's conference yeah yeah
so I'm interested it we talked a little
bit about the other day but I'm
interested kind of in what's going on in
that community like what other coach is
talking about what's new what's
tried-and-true like what is your
relationship to that you know situation
put me right on this I don't know I
don't want to talk about anything you
know you're not comfortable talking
about but it's you know I think a lot of
people listening to this or I need a
coach how do I find a coach who are the
coaches are looking or poking around the
internet what's available well that's a
different question with finding a coach
because I get a lot of those questions
too but from Boulder standpoint I did
not really take part because I really
like to stay an outsider and I talked to
two or three coaches up there that I
know and I'm good friends with and
they're very similar they like to stay
on the outside I like to learn from
different sports my own activities a lot
of reading a lot of input I don't like
to for lack of a better description
conform to these rules of how to teach
triathlon mine I think after 20 years of
coaching this and sort of keeping those
athletes healthy motivated athletes
coming back years later saying man I
never felt as fit and healthy and not
injured as I did back those years now
they can't train like that anymore with
kids in life and so on but that's the
rule that's the compliment to me and
they love that time that they use that
window in their time of life to get fit
and healthy and carry that for years and
years forward right and maintain some
sort of healthy and fit lifestyle but ya
know I didn't really partake in the
festivities in Boulder okay so in the
reading like you said you know you try
to get your information from your you're
trying to stay up on what's going on
like as there been anything that you've
come across in the last you know year or
two that's altered your perspective or
that you've incorporated into your
training that's different
maybe what you were doing four or five
years ago like has it evolved or do you
just it's definitely evolved especially
from a nutrition standpoint it's evolved
from a recovery standpoint and even more
the need of recovery and sleep and how
we're doing our macro cycles versus the
intensity so that we're training and
also the importance of really separating
athletes that they do not fit any type
of plan wouldn't move back to the whole
coaching according to conformed plans
right here's your plans reactive if I
found that no two athletes are the same
and one person with a little bit of
intensity and a lot of endurance does
great and that same that person that
looks the same has trained the same the
same background blows up with that you
know and it's just a lot of listening
it's a lot of communicating and then you
know a lot of my athletes will laugh
when they hear this but it's also a lot
of saying you know what don't overthink
it you've got to get in these next six
months because we've got to build that
platform properly and then we can start
messing around with different types of
training because then you're ready cool
all right well let's uh let's close this
thing down what do we got going tomorrow
we have a two-hour trail run we're going
to head up to the Honda Fit crest which
is absolutely gorgeous
what's the elevation up there yeah start
about 8,000 feet oh my god and we're
gonna go fix isn't enough yeah but it's
just so pretty you have to see I know
and then social act right now the idea
of doing a 14 mile run it like 8,000
feet 14 miles that okay on trails as
well as without elevation as well it's
just it's too hard to do that you it
will probably be 11 to 12 you get in 6
miles an hour when you're doing these in
our shorts right we're not yeah okay but
we will that would definitely get some
looks up there be it tonight it's winter
hat yeah I think people think we're
going to fly off that reel and then
we'll start with a swim in the morning
nice long stretch out some full-on just
recovery will swim backstroke and we'll
make her feel like butterfly
right we're gonna have to yeah and then
when we get back like we've been
training in the biggest paddles
available and we're going to step it
down to some smaller ones who got too
much I'm looking forward to yeah I felt
that today I think yeah I didn't think i
mean someone in a pool I just crank with
paddles like I didn't expect to feel
that like lactic acid buildup in the
shoulder that's like God cool man wants
like to be here 48-hour training camp
this is great man we should do more of
these yeah we gain crazy yeah let's just
choose destination yeah like I got a
five o'clock flight what are we doing
tomorrow we'll get back down to
Sacramento we're all going home yeah
cool okay yeah there's lots of plans out
see what happens you know yeah let's
just get through this race you know at
first and then we'll talk about what
comes after Caroline okay and Caroline
will you come back and do the podcast
with me properly we'll tell your whole
story awesome cool
all right thanks you guys let's try to
do one more maybe like when we're in
Stockholm right before the race doing
laughter time permitting or whatever
yeah I feel post race download yeah we
definitely do that people are going to
be a stories to tell for sure whatever
happens so anyway alright thanks you
guys appreciate it
peace lights